cegid hôpitaux de la mort où
l'infrastructure s'effondre ou les
moyens sont devenus inadmissible et
honteux par rapport au minimum du
respect de la dignité même
il est inadmissible aujourd'hui qu'une
pluie fasse effondrés des toitures
d'aider des hôpitaux
il est inadmissible aujourd'hui à
l'intérieur des hôpitaux nous puissions
mourir ou défaillance technique
combien de fois interne où résident
infirmiers
ils vont nous pousser une ambulance en
taille avant nous soulever sur nous dans
la force de nos bras
un patient pour lutter remonté après une
opération parce que les ascenseurs en
question était en panne mais encore
je
mais
on est passé par plusieurs mouvements du
personnel médical et para médical
pendant des années qu'il s'agissait de
cris d'allah et ça j'essaie d'appels à
l'aide d'un secteur sinistré aujourd'hui
s'agit d'un cri de deuil et de douleur
s'agit plus d'une goutte d'eau qui a
fait déborder le vase s'agit d'une
goutte de sang qui a fait bouger une
colère qui était latente pendant des
années suite au décès de notre frère ne
sont plus prêts à faire machine arrière
il n'est plus qu'à être sûr de se taire
on ne fait pas uniquement pour nous on
le fait pour vous citoyen